[Music]  Pete Davidson and Cassie David call it  quits after two years of dating  does he have dad's approval yeah a  hundred percent yeah us me eating  waffles he really loves that I'm dating  a comedian that's Pete and Cassie  gushing over each other last April but  he recently revealed they've gone their  separate ways the Saturday Night Live  star confirmed the news during an  interview on open late with Peter  Rosenberg airing at Thursday on complex  he said quote were not together anymore  very talented girl she'll be great and  she'll do fine Pete and Cassie who is  the daughter of Seinfeld co-creator  Larry David often shared sweet moments  together on social media and in a  heartfelt post in March 2017 Pete  thanked Cassie for her support as he  maintains his sobriety  [Music]